this blast 40 calendars I've signed over
9,000 calendars today and no that's not
just a joke I've literally signed about
9,000 calendars in 12 hours this is the
last of them this is the very last of
them this box contains 40 and it's all
there is I can't even fathom or
understand or explain how I finished at
this point this is it so I thought it'd
be best if I did it with you guys if you
guys are here to join me on this
monumentous occasion then oh boy is it
gonna be a good one
my hand is practically swollen I don't
know if it looks like it on camera but
my fingers are actually swollen my
knuckles a slightly knobby my hand is in
incredible pain or at least it was in
the last stretch all the pain seemed to
mysteriously vanish away from my body
and suddenly I'm fine so if you guys
want to see the very last special
moments where I get to sign and be done
with signing these calendars then buckle
up pay attention and don't go anywhere
because who knows what shenanigans will
happen to try to prevent me from
finishing this fight once and for all
and I've double-checked I've looked
around everywhere there's no secret box
hiding anywhere this is the last I'm
here by myself Evan had to jaw off the
other important work he hung around for
12 hours so he was a huge help but I get
to finish it just by myself this is it
this is all this is this is all that's
left
this is all that's left okay count down
with me
40 what's up I don't screw these up I'm
gonna I want to try to put a little
extra pizzazz in them but I don't know
if it's entirely possible to do that at
this point I'm so goddamn tired I've
been running off of like pure adrenaline
oh wow wow i cocked that one up oh man
is this completely numb so I just go put
a nice oops
see poopsie on that one uh and then
we're gonna call that one a day this
one's special it's special because it's
a mistake if it's a mistake it's very
special and I love it more for the fact
that it is a mistake I don't know if the
person who gives it will think of that
but you know that is what it is
I've lost count you guys been counting
good
I honestly numbers hold no meaning for
me anymore nothing holds any meaning for
me anymore all I know is his life where
I've somehow constructed my entire
existence to culminate in this moment
this moment where I finish I have done
it again I screwed it up
see oh boy culminated to this moment
right here and I don't even it is it
still streaming I don't see chat anymore
I'm gonna assume that you're there
because otherwise a [ __ ] show to end all
[ __ ] shows of course when I'm signing
the last ones who knows if I'm actually
live or not or if it's completely broken
because that's entirely possible
I screwed up again oh man I've had the
past you'd be flawless and these last
ones are getting all kinds of bones
about I'm gonna assume you there if
you're there just scream as loud as you
can in the comments and I'll probably
know are you counting
that was nor this one spinkle t this one
guru and that's pronounced cool if you
guys know how to pronounce quickly
please make a video and post it on
Twitter always my favorite number I
don't know skillet you know there's no
one I get to ten left now this box is
not faced there's actually slower than
the other ones because I have to spin
them around myself this would normally
be Evans job at Evans not here anymore
oh wow it's kind of bones to let me draw
a little tiny bucket in there okay are
you ready we're getting closer and then
we're gonna get two and then are you
guys were probably already seen all the
art inside but I don't need to show you
again I did an Instagram stream and then
I think I talked about it on Twitter I
think I just said on Twitter about how
the la gangs finally got me which would
be a valid reasoning for why this is
taking me so long and why I've been in a
hell of my own design I mean if I'm an
egotistical bastard then my hell truly
would be staring it
shoes of my own ass for all eternity
this is uh numbers and this one's
numbers hmm
and III don't even know how can I even
tell if there's ten left I just let that
pile up there
that's probably fun we're so close
I've only got left
we're down to the wire how many this is
this time this might be ten let's let's
assume this is ten because otherwise I'm
actually gonna know it's nine damn it I
didn't even get to that's nine left
everybody count with me nine like it's
like New Year's a bit I earned my
freedom I'll become a real boy after
this and eight is this seven I don't
know seven I think six oh here here
comes here comes five wait
five four three
oh I'm about to cry two
[Music]
I'm gone I'm gone oh I don't even know
if it's streaming I'm done
oh I have to do something special this
is the last calendar oh I don't even
know Hospital calendar what a journey
oh I can't even explain it this is thank
you for believing in me oh you guys
don't understand you guys don't
understand I mean you probably have
something linka whoever gets this one
let me know
tweet tweet this one at me but you guys
you guys probably understand but you
also I don't I don't know if you
understand cuz I don't know if I can
explain it to you cuz a lot of people
said I was nuts obviously because I
tried to sign it all in one go and and
listen to me if you've never really
listened to me seriously
listen to me now because this is
important when you have nothing but time
to think you end up with a lot of saw
the thoughts swirling around
and this the signing came at an
extremely inconvenient time
I just as some of you may have been
noticing I've been wearing this youtuber
s brand it's from the YouTube creator
side and this story might get long and
windy but it is important so please pay
attention closely I went into that
summit thinking that I would be okay if
I stopped doing YouTube I really did I
went into that with the mindset that was
like I have accomplished everything I've
wanted to accomplish I have a gross
amount of success and I I had come to
terms with the idea that I could stop
and it wasn't that I planned to stop it
wasn't that I was going to stop it was
it was I went into the mindset of this
YouTube summit all about creators
talking about YouTube creators and how
they're important to the platform the
stats are up in yada yada yada and it
was it was good but a lot of that
mindset had to do with how I felt last
year and this is all gonna make sense I
promise it will and please listen
closely last year I was in dark times a
lot of you knew it from the very first
video that I kind of posted that hinted
at it the one I posted where I said I
feel lost and what that came from was
this kind of burden of success it's it's
a weird thing to even talk about it it
was a weirder thing to even complain
about because the last thing I ever
wanted was to complain about the fact
that I was so successful I felt lost
because I had things that I didn't want
and I had I had things were falling into
my lap whether I earned it or not and it
wasn't a matter of it wasn't a matter of
like what I was making uh it was like
whatever I made it was it was well
received and it was well accepted and
and I started to question like the why
of it all because it's no secret
that I'm extremely wealthy and I'm not
saying that to brag I'm saying it to put
it in perspective wealth has very little
meaning for me I don't spend my money on
practically anything I have a nice car
and I have a nice house but other than
that I I can't even fathom why I would
want more of that once you have enough
what else is there and then I was in
this conundrum and spiral of what am I
making videos for what am i doing things
for and and I promise you this will tie
back into this specific task that I set
out for me and the mindset that I had
when I was going into signing 35,000
calendars in a row last year I kept
going down you know I made a video I
feel lost part to the saying like I
really appreciated you guys like
speaking up and encouraging me and I
meant it it was no lie
it was no life but I couldn't keep the
thoughts from creeping in the back of my
mind like what was I really making
videos for is it for the money like I
don't care about the money I don't care
about the fame I don't care about any of
that I've been saying that since the
beginning my channel and it's always
been true but it seemed like the results
were saying different things you know
what I mean my videos were doing
wonderfully incredibly I was getting
millions of views I could do practically
no wrong and I would still find success
and so that pushed me that pushed me to
both create things that I'd never
created before hence a date with more
Flair hands who killed mark Blair hence
markiplier TV all those things and it
pushed me to make those things because I
was rebelling against these thoughts
like I make to make I don't make to find
success and I wanted to somehow prove it
to myself if no one else and last year
when I took my hiatus I was in an
extremely low point where I kind of
reached this lie I was telling myself
and I was like I making because I feel
the creative driver I'm making because I
feel like I need to sustain what I have
and that ate away at me and so when I
took my break I really did take my break
and I thought about it and I came back
stronger than ever before but I came
with the mindset that I am proud of what
I accomplished and if it ended I'd be
okay with that and that's true like that
is true my channel died tomorrow or got
deleted tomorrow I'd be fine with it but
the reason that it pertains to this
singular event is very important and
this is what I've been building towards
I went into the YouTube creator summit
with the idea that I I could I could be
okay with it all being over but I left
with the mindset that I wanted to be the
best youtuber in the world and I can't
point to a singular event in that entire
summit I I can't point to one
conversation I had because I had many
and I spoke with so many people about
what it meant to be a youtuber like
getting to know other creators on in
conversations that I never bothered to
happen and knowing like what what what
YouTube was leading towards and at the
crux of it all I had this realization I
was standing on top of the roof hotel
staring at the New York skyline and I
just saw and in the entire expanse of my
view I saw that there were millions of
people in that city millions and each
and every one of them had the potential
to view one thing or another and the
only thing that separated them from me
was the drive to commit to it and when I
when I when I realize that what the only
thing separating me from who I was six
years ago was the decision that I needed
to commit to something that was bigger
than myself the only thing that makes me
look back at my old self six years ago
more than six years ago now when I
wasn't doing YouTube was that I had no
commitment in my life I had no
dedication I had no desire to push
myself farther than I've ever done
before and I pushed myself so hard you
guys know I have up to this point to get
here like to find the success
and over the past year I've been
wrestling with myself of whether the
effort was
and and in doing so I reached a
conclusion that I feel was correct in a
way and correct for some but wrong for
me and here's how it ties into this
because this has been this is been dealt
the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
coming my way this task of signing
35,000 hasn't been coming for a month I
knew was as soon as the the calendars
were done being produced I would have to
do it and when I when I walked into that
factory and the full realization of how
much [ __ ] work it would take to get
through these goddamn calendars it hit
me full in the face and at first I
thought I was going to be like okay I'll
do what I can
I'll figure it out and then over the
next forever
I will just fiddle down a couple at a
time Deven I had this realization that
this signing calendars is not an amazing
feat I am NOT a goddamn hero for signing
calendars people have signed [ __ ] before
in in more efficient ways than I ever
have but when I looked at this and I saw
what I could do and I saw what I needed
to do but also I saw what it represented
to me like what it represented to me was
just a monumental mountain of work there
was no easy way about it there's no
cheating way there's no there's no like
quick route there's no shortcut it's
just [ __ ] work you do it and it's
done you do it and do it and do it until
it's done
and me being the insane person that I am
I don't just want to do something to do
it I want to do things that have meaning
in it I want to do things that are
important to me and signing these
calendars was more than just a
representation of me doing work because
at the end of the day this is me
scribbling my name on but to me like
this there's something I owed people I
owed it to you guys to sign these and I
owed it to you guys to get them out as
quickly as I possibly could
and admittedly there are other
circumstances that made me decide to do
it this way because I have to leave town
next week and I didn't want to be
pushing this forever and also I had this
ambition to do big better projects and
it all came down to what am I willing to
do to separate myself from the person I
was to the person I could be and at the
end of the day and each day when my hand
was hurting and my arm was cramping and
my elbows like for some reason the elbow
and my my shoulder here are like the
most painful parts each day I could look
back what I did the day before and I
could be proud of what I did
it's just mundane work but I was proud
of it cuz I pushed myself not to the
point of death I wouldn't do that but I
push myself to give something back and I
think and I think that's a
representative of Who I am like I I
think we all have moments where we look
back at our past selves and we cringe
inwardly or we regret mistakes that we
have I don't want to do that I want to I
used to do that I used to look back in
myself and I used to be like regretful
of who I was I don't want to do that
anymore
I want to look back at who I was and be
proud of what I did to get where I am
today and I want to be proud of
everything that I've done up until this
point and in this stupid task in this
monumentally insane task of trying to
get thirty five thousand calendars
signed in a week and a half a total of
seven days actually seven actual days of
signing say I have no idea I am as proud
not just to myself but of you guys for
believing in me because this is an
insane idea
this isn't it is a stupid [ __ ] idea
that's it's so dumb it's so dumb and
egotistical to think
that I could sell calendar with my naked
butt on it and raise money for charities
but it's that stupid [ __ ] idea that
raised a half a million of dollars for
the cancer research I stood it's this
stupid idea that did it and the one
thing that separated it the one thing
that made this stupid [ __ ] idea work
was that I committed to like I just
decided that I was going to do it and I
did it as all it is if you like you
could listen with secrets of successful
[ __ ] stuff like that inspirational
speakers like you could listen to those
guys all day and to their credit they
they are inspirational and they do have
good words but at the end of the day
it's something that my dad taught me
like sometimes you just gotta put nose
to the grindstone you go look at it and
it doesn't matter how much it sucks it
doesn't matter how how boring it is it
doesn't matter how mundane it doesn't
matter what kind of [ __ ] you see the
road to your goal and it's paved with
broken glass you can [ __ ] and moan the
whole way but at the end of the day you
just gotta walk you just gotta do you
just got sign whatever it takes to get
you to your goal sometimes it's just
something you gotta do that's all it is
that's all it is anyway the only reason
I'm blabbering at you is because I've
been doing nothing but thinking for the
past seven days and I want to be better
I know I'm good now I know I'm good I
I'm you tist achill I know I'm good I
know I make good [ __ ] I want to be
better I don't make better [ __ ] don't
make bigger stuff gonna push myself want
to see where this road goes
I want to set goals that I can't always
achieve but I'll always try good that's
who I am and maybe it can work for some
of you and I'll stop blabbering for a
little bit I am incredibly tired and in
an enormous amount of pain this shoulder
is currently cramping up
right now so thank you everybody so much
for watching you take care of yourself Z
we'll be shipping out very soon and just
thanks for giving me the time to do this
crazy task of mine so take care of y'all
have a good night
I'll see you soon I'm probably gonna
take a day off I'm probably gonna take a
day off tomorrow and just sleep maybe
watch Deadpool so thanks good as always
see you bye-bye
toodles